marc est de retour et il cherche encore
l'amour et cette fois ci ça va chauffer
j'ai jamais eu autant pied qui se
battaient préau qui sera l'heureux élu
elle plaît on m'invite à venir aux
sorties mais bien
quelle horrible
trop de marques
auxquelles femmes elles sont prêtes à
tout même le pire pour conquérir son
coeur j'ai découvert plein de facettes
des candidates que je ne connaissais pas
tu devrais te mettre à genoux et me dire
merci ouah c'est le cas les accessoires
j'adore et c'est donc parler les femmes
et aux alertes cougar alerte cougar et
améliore façon de faire cela c'est par
le mariage je pense que c'est un peu
trop tôt pour se dire il tient également
à vous offrir ça ça grossit
neuf femmes pour un seul homme qui sera
rallumé la flamme
c'est pas vrai